kaylee mcininnie the white house press
secretary
that has all of our hearts a flutter she
is just
so incredibly good at her job had
another greatest hit and it
shows us something that i think a lot of
conservatives
have misunderstood about the press and
the role of the press secretary
for a great many years now kaylee
mcanenny was asked this ridiculous
question
she was asked the question actually
multiple times first the reporter says
how many deaths you know are acceptable
how many deaths from coronavirus you
know will
will your boss feel comfortable with you
know what
would he find to be acceptable so it's
kind of ridiculous question in the first
place
basically along the lines of hey sir
when did you stop beating your wife
but she answered the question at first
politely and she gave him a nice long
answer
then this reporter followed up with more
or less
the same question and asked how many
deaths
would be tolerable by november and
macaneny unleashed
americans when voters go to the polls in
november and they want to judge the
president on his response to this
pandemic
what is the number of dead americans
that they should
tolerate as ha and where they can argue
that yes
he successfully defeated the pandemic i
think um
you know you're asking the wrong
question the right question is where did
where did the data
ask caleb when i and i answered your
question once but if you ask it twice it
doesn't make it any better of a question
so i'll respond in kind i've given you
one answer i'll continue to extrapolate
upon that that
he always listened to the science the
president when dr fauci and dr burke
said
you need to shut down the economy that
was hard for the president you know in a
typical year 120 000 people die of
suicide and drug overdose it's been a
typical year
and doctors have said when you shut down
an economy for an extended period of
time that number gets greater
people don't show up for their cancer
diagnosis are there a litany of of
results when you close down an economy
but closing down the economy for this
amount of time
kept us far below the 2.2 million number
as we start to reopen we keep in mind
the people who are missing their
screening appointments the people
um who are not who are succumbing to
suicide and drug overdose because of
economic hardship this president
made the right choice uh it was a
delicate balance and he did it exactly
as he should guided by data
and we are far below 2.2 million dead
americans because of the actions of
president trump
be still my beating heart what a
perfect answer i i actually don't even
want to get into the substance
of the answer or rather the substance of
the policies
that she's defending right her job is to
defend the president's policies
on coronavirus trump has done you know
relatively a very good job we can get
into those policies another day
i just want to focus on the answer
because what kayleigh mcinerney
understands is what donald trump
understands
is what a lot of republicans didn't
understand until recently
the press is not the press
the news media are not the news media
they are leftist operatives whose sole
purpose
is to destroy conservatives and
republicans
that's what they're there for that's why
they show up
the press secretary's job is not to
field
questions and provide information to
unbiased objective newsmen that has not
been true
for a very very very long time if it was
ever true
in the first place the job of the press
secretary
is to pummel the press the job of the
press secretary is to fight back against
the press
in the same way that a republican
presidential debater
will push back against a democratic
presidential debater that's what it is
that's the analogy
there is no press the pres the press is
gone if the press ever existed in the
first place
the unbiased neutral press is gone and
so
every day what you see playing out or
what you should see playing out and what
you do with kaylee mcinanny
is you see the press secretary
as the one debate opponent and the press
meaning the leftist operatives
as the other debate opponent and when
you go up against kaylee mcinanny
guess who's going to win that's right
our terrific
press secretary
[Music]
you